it's crazy cuz Macklemore like previous
to blowing up a big leg lamp and so is
Black Eyed Peas
that is true [__] right it is
bridging the gap once dad at forget the
folding was like some other man is fine
man like everybody has their Tom and
some people don't
is he gonna ports you anymore like I
feel like you're in a place to where no
matter what you're always gonna be able
to beat up music like whether or not you
ever have a platinum album we have a
[__] top ten single or whatever is
that something you can give a [__] to
the zoo to accomplish or you just you
know if it happens it happens every
artist growth whether or not you know
people screaming underground or
independent or I'm indeed everything
sounds sexy you know everybody wants to
get a Grammy
everybody dimplex like Ramius would be
amazing I just think for my focus back
into what's gonna get me there you know
staying absorbs man like you said like
maybe the last go-round so we did
just I don't just place handle the most
in Russia's dress place for destroyed
that's what like myself it's like my
favorite rapper Just Blaze my favorite
producer I should wear my Action Bronson
another fellow I trap I'm a really big
fan I know you're a won't a head just
put out that cannon be free stylist and
me too we [__] love and I know
actually he's like what first face but
now he's like yeah I don't hear that
anymore yeah I actually
yeah he's [__] me to see what about
what are your thoughts on riff raff at
first at first riff raff I don't know I
didn't really know I got get it now I
get it I get the gum Oh [__] white
trash superstars [__] you know I don't
like at first like I don't know he seems
cool he's finally a comedian he's
hilarious
basically I you know I think man is
making sense for him to blend all that
[__] in the guy but I don't know enough
to judge musically final judgment but I
mean we I guess well yo appreciate your
time as always
I already know
you